hey guys I'm really excited because
right now i am at home in Pittsburgh and
I'm just letting you guys know that I'm
doing a Pittsburgh meet up now I'm from
here and I've never actually done one of
these so all of you guys who live in the
local area tweet me every time i'm home
and asked to do a meetup I'm finally
doing one I'm gonna be having it at
crazy mocha in south side this Saturday
October 26 starting at one o'clock link
is in the description for the facebook
invite so make sure you guys if you are
going to be able to come make sure you
go there RSVP so that we have an idea of
how many people are gonna show up and if
you can't come feel free to say you're
not coming but don't lie and say you are
coming so if you just have the need to
interact with this link I want to be a
part of the conversation you can say
you're not coming i'm that's totally
fine so i chose this location because I
absolutely am obsessed with crazy milk I
now it's a local coffee shop and I used
to work out of this shop every single
day I would set up shop I'd bring hard
drives I'd bring cameras in to put i
just sit at one of their tables all day
eating their food and drinking the
coffee and using their Wi-Fi also most
importantly to note this video the
iphone bill 300-page video which went
viral in like 2007 throughs actual legit
viral video so i made this video in
their coffee shop and if you guys attend
more importantly than getting to meet me
you'll be able to see the outlet
featured in this video i'm really
excited to meet you guys and you all
mean so much to me and i love doing
these meetups and getting to meet you
guys because it's so crazy that I see
your comments and I see your tweets but
actually give you guys a hug and get to
talk to you and I get to meet you and
see you that you guys are real people
and it's it's awesome so I love going to
good cons I love going to playlists in
and all of the other crazy meetups that
we have but most importantly this is my
hometown this is my city and this is one
of my favorite places to go when i'm
home so i can't wait to see you guys
make sure if you do come you dress warm
because the coffee shop isn't probably
going to be able to hold all of us if as
many people rsvp'd actually are going to
come dress warm you may be outside for a
little bit but my hug will be so warm
sounds really creepy anyways I will see
you guys this saturday i'm a
be wearing a onesie I'm not sure if I'm
gonna wear this I'm probably not gonna
wear it anything could happen I'll see
you guys Saturday dress warm bring
gloves and hugs and I'll see you guys
later